pour décrypter cette situation un mail
charrier est à mes côtés bonjour à un
malade un jour damien on va faire le
point cette ville de l'iscid champ's
d'abord passer sous contrôle russe
concrètement qu'est ce que ça change
pour les deux camps alors ça change
moralement beaucoup de choses l'isie
jones on s'attendait de toute manière à
ce qu'elle tombe c'était la volonté des
russes en fait d'éviter d'avoir la ville
ce qui est au dessus la ville de
severodonezk en face à face en quelque
sorte et il avait contourné par le sud
voilà en face en bluff qui sépare
severodonezk d'un côté les sites chance
de l'autre vous connaissez bien votre
jours du coup d'envoi là c'était c'était
le choix qui avait été fait et donc
forcément c'est pour les russes ça leur
apporte la solution en fait et ça montre
effectivement que le prix à payer les
ukrainiens et lourd parce que lorsque on
se retrouve comme ça avec l'armée russe
qui je vous le rappelle continuent de
pilonner 24 heures sur 24 c'est ce qu'on
entend ils sont là des tirs d'artillerie
constante depuis que ils commencent
effectivement cette cette campagne sur
le donbass la difficulté est très grande
alors il y avait la possibilité choix
pour les ukrainiens de partir en fait de
reculer sauf que dans ce cas là c'est à
dire qui lâche du terrain et le
président zelensky est pas très
favorable mais en même temps s'il reste
que là le risque c'est des morts on n'a
pas le chiffre des morts on n'a pas le
chiffre donc plus des bébés c'est ce
qu'on appelle les blessés catégorie à
c'est à dire ceux qui ne peuvent pas
revenir au combat a priori il va être
important parce qu'on est quand même sur
des combats qui sont extrêmement
importants et on le voit quand on entend
les habitants là qui disent tout a été
coupée on est sans eau on est sans gaz
etc c'est dans l'immense difficulté de
ces populations maintenant de l'ukraine
qui sont face aux combats qui sont très
coupé qui peuvent à un moment donné
complètement aller râler contre le
président céline ski parce que le prix à
payer est extrêmement lourd c'est un
pays proxis un pays qui effectivement un
an et sous les bombes et effectivement
il ya des morts où il ya des gens qui
vivent dans les conditions très
difficiles a contrario de ce que l'on
peut voir dans l'ukraine occidentale de
l'autre partie dans lequel de temps en
temps il peut y avoir des tirs
effectivement mais qui a repris
quasiment une activité normale on
l'entend souvent du côté de kiev donc ça
nous permet d'avoir une un jugement
assez précis lorsqu'un train de sauter
les troupes russes sont en train de
progresser en gros d'est en ouest
severodonezk
désormais les sites science quelles sont
les prochaines étapes pour les russes
maintenant alors ce qui est sûr c'est
que en fait il avait un plan quelque
sorte qu'ils étaient mis en place qui
était de se dire que pour avoir le don
basse il fallait qu'ils fonctionnent
parce qu'on appelle les oblasts c'est à
dire les anciennes régions et que ceux
qui sont en train de condat voir
maintenant c'est le blast de lougansk
qui donc leur donne leur continuité
territoriale vers le nord après il faut
qu'ils récupèrent celui qui en dessous
c'est à dire l'oblast de donetsk est là
maintenant ils pourront du coup dire on
a le don bas ce qui était au départ la
volonté qu'ils avaient donc ils se sont
occupés de l'ouganda avec lee jones on
vient de signer effectivement le fait
que maintenant ils vont en voir le set
blast là et après maintenant il va
falloir qu'ils attaquent sont celui de
donetsk qui va être effectivement plus
conséquent mais qui va effectivement
aller dans la même continuité et la
grande question derrière ce sera une
fois qu'ils auront en basse une fois que
c'est ce qui était effectivement assurée
avec le pourtour de la mer d'azov qu'est
ce qu'on fait et alors s'arrêter voilà
c'est à dire que soient les ukrainiens
est ce que dans ce cas là ils seront de
l'armement qui leur sera rivé est-ce
qu'ils auront surtout des hommes neufs
ce que je vous disais on connaît pas le
nombre de leurs blessés on connaît pas
le nombre de morts donc à un moment
donné même sans armement si vous n'avez
pas les gens derrière pour les tenir
c'est compliqué est-ce qu'ils auront
effectivement cet appel d'air là ou pas
et si l'on passe à taper albert là est
ce que les russes s'arrêteront et se
dire on l'a maintenant on va rentrer
dans une espèce de négociation où est-ce
qu'ils auront envie de continuer leur
appétit aller vers odessa par exemple là
où par exemple les turcs ou le président
magron dernièrement au sommet de l'otan
a redit que non il n'était pas question
de laisser tomber au dessin